the gyro can experience yeah that's uh
the the emotional side of fighting like
the emotional side of losses like when
you see guys just weeping in their
locker room and like remember mmm though
the hardest one for me was Aldo after
mcgregor knocked him out and he was just
in his locker room just weeping like god
damn that dude that's a tough one too
you know that's that's gonna stay like
an infamy you know I mean you know
forever and oh wait Connors fly the
worst guy cuz he's gonna tell everybody
about it everybody's gonna want to cover
it and that's the way it goes it was
such a picture-perfect punch - yeah I
mean he slides back only drops out left
hand and I was in a crowd and I was I
was told I was getting the winner of
that fight and the one that went down
like that I just knew that wasn't gonna
happen really yeah I just felt it like I
thought I thought I was gonna win back
then we didn't I didn't know much about
Conor I feel like at that point you know
so I thought Aldo was gonna win and I
was gonna get a rematch with him and
then when when when Connor did that and
here I'm talking about go I'm gonna go
up to 55 my dad it was my chance
yeah that the Aldo fight was crazy
because I think that was the first time
that anybody ever really disrespected
although yes Aldo was the [ __ ] man
for so long I mean he didn't the crazy
thing about Aldo is he's still only 32
years old yeah like we were talking
about that with the Marlin fight right
wait you know is he really you know
they've been following him since the WEC
yeah I mean he was like 20 then so yeah
kind of has to know yeah I mean he was
WC Champion a long [ __ ] time ago man
yeah you know I mean you go back and
think about when he knocked out Cub
Swanson with that flying knee that was a
long time ago it's like a double name
right yeah - he was so [ __ ] athletic
explosive know what when did he stop
throwing leg kicks I don't know man I
wonder I would like to ask him I wonder
if like he's got injuries or something
like that maybe nobody thought the first
time he threw a leg kick and then I took
him down on it I'm the second one and
then he's not that's the last time you
do a leg kick and bolt our fights it's
crazy because if you watch his early
career like watch the Urijah Faber fight
it is one of the most horrific displays
of destroying someone's leg you've ever
in a fight yeah it's so fast man there's
no loading just now yeah that's the
thing no loading he would just just whip
those hips and right well you know he
was a soccer player like a really good
soccer right you ever seen videos of him
play soccer I see him a juggling ball
he's like a pro oh yeah like he could
have been a professor and I think soccer
players first of all their legs are so
conditioned because they're doing
although they're basically sprinting all
the time they're running on Linux miles
a game I heard yeah and they're going
left and right left and right there way
side to side like they apparently have
the highest instances of ACL blowouts
yeah yeah it makes sense
oh yeah but because of those legs you
know although just he was like a whip
those legs were just cracked that's why
I thought with him a Marlin gonna fight
him like we're gonna see some like cakes
but neither one really you know got him
off I wonder I wonder why Aldo stop
throwing leg kicks I really wonder like
wonder I mean he's got something right
you know some injury yeah maybe a hip
injury yeah could be a lot of those
kickboxer guys as they get older their
hips start falling apart you know it's
it seems to be a big issue with some
guys like John Wayne par needs a hip
replacement right yeah I mean he just
had his last fight he won in a boxing
match yeah I saw that
which is great huge for the man dude
he's such a good guy to follow yeah he's
a good energy good positive dude and so
is his whole family he's just like great
daughters do not like 30 fighters apiece
yeah she's a beast man I think she's
like 14 now she's amazing yeah he's he's
something special but the poor guy he's
been fighting over the last year or two
with a really [ __ ] up hip yeah like me
it's falling apart man they're like you
got to have a hip replacement the whole
insides just torn apart all right I'm
not looking forward to the future man
I'm just you know what I'm looking
forward to the future with regenerative
women
well yeah well you had stem cell I had
some stem cells in my shoulder yeah we
talked about you don't give it enough
time
the thing about the stem cells is it
really takes like four or five months
before it actually likes an eye and
starts healing things and a lot of guys
like yourself I mean you don't you don't
gather any dust waiting for shopping at
the bit
[Applause]